now we know you're not on social media
so we wanted to just share some of our
favorite responses to the iconic wanda
so you are aware of what the people
think of her um elizabeth olsen my lord
and savior
that's mother right there if she kills
everyone then she had a reason to do it
and wanda can be the villain all she
wants as long as she's having fun what
do you make of how much love she's
getting i really love being called
someone's mom you know
that's like a thing i didn't know about
but i'm called it a lot and i i don't
know at what point this started
happening i'd love for someone to teach
me the evolution of that phrase
i'm not aware i mean it's amazing and
it's hilarious and at least it's funny
you know it's funny stuff
one day
i knew somewhere later you'd show up
i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview
then what are you here for
i need your help
guess what
what do you know about the multiverse
fans are speculating a scarlet witch
solo film what would you want to see for
wanda next and does she ever get a happy
ending i have no idea what i want to see
and that's what i'm i'm most excited
about sharing this film because i really
want the fan interaction i want to hear
what people want from her next um i
think this film is going to surprise
lots of people and hopefully make them
excited for for what's to come this film
sold more uh pre-sale tickets than any
other film this year people are excited
how does that feel i didn't know that
that feels great i love hearing this
information from journalists and from
interviews i never know any of this
stuff until someone tells me
it's pretty incredible um fans are also
debating constantly who would win in a
fight dr strange or wanda who do you
think stronger well if it's just about
fighting i think i will win yes
[Music]